welcome to the show begin this newshour
with the investigation into the bullet
that killed our journalist shireen abu
akla the u.s state department says a
third-party examination of the fragment
has been inconclusive but it says
gunfire from israeli army positions was
likely responsible for her death in may
u.s state department spokesman ned price
has released a statement saying
ballistic experts determined the bullet
was badly damaged which prevented a
clear conclusion
he went on to say the u.s security
coordinator concluded that gunfire from
israeli forces positioned
was likely responsible for the death of
shireen abu akhla the u.s security
coordinator found no reason to believe
that this was intentional but rather the
result of tragic circumstances
well we'll get the result the reaction
from stephanie decker in west jerusalem
soon but let's go first to mike hanna in
washington dc and mike we've heard more
details there about what the state
department had to say about this do you
get the sense that given how much
attention and pressure was placed upon
this case this is an attempt by the us
to draw online under all of this
well that would appear to be the
intention it is an exceedingly
inconclusive report and significant
within that as well is that comment
there uh that it's not possible to uh
establish that the shooting was
intentional now to reach that conclusion
requires going into the mind of whoever
did the shooting so just that statement
would appear to uh underweigh the uh
opinions of those who believe that the
us wants to finish this affair move on
and it does so by issuing what is
clearly an inconclusive report now there
has been some reaction already from some
human rights organizations uh one of the
least critical is saying that this is a
travesty of justice we've also heard
comments such as uh you are now in a
situation where the perpetrator is
examining themselves so there is a lot
of criticism and this is going to
increase on a report that is clearly
very inconclusive stating though that it
does appear that the shooting occurred
from the israeli army positions but
saying as well that the bullet was so
damaged that it could not be properly
matched to a specific weapon now the
palestinians have been insistent that
they will not accept any finding unless
that bullet is matched to a gun now that
is a critical issue as well which the
so-called independent investigators
appear not to have addressed their
findings that the
shooting itself is inconclusive but they
add there should be no blame attached so
any question about accountability is
thrown out of the window in this
specific report mike of course this is a
very delicate time diplomatically given
that uh the president is expected to
visit the region uh quite soon saying
that though do you imagine you've
already mentioned ngos there and human
rights groups do you imagine that the
pressure will continue to pile up on the
authorities there to find a more
decisive response to to this inquiry
well yes that is exceedingly likely
there has been a lot of pressure from
congress surprisingly some might argue
which has been heavily supportive of
israel but many within congress have
demanded that the administration do its
part in getting to the bottom of this
affair
several members of congress have made
very clearly that this type of shooting
has occurred regularly with the israeli
army responsible in the past and they
are insistent uh that the administration
should play its role in getting to the
bottom of exactly the circumstances that
led to the death of the al jazeera
journalist so this pressure is going to
continue to ramp up not only from human
rights organizations but also from
congress itself there are likely to be
questions asked and demands made that
the administration pushed this further
uh that an inconclusive report is not
acceptable mike hello in washington dc
thank you well let's stay with the story
and bring in stephanie decker in west
jerusalem stephanie of course for those
people hoping for a conclusive results
to this investigation this may be a
frustrating and disappointing time what
are people saying where you are
well the palestinians didn't expect
anything conclusive or certainly not
accountability or justice when they
heard that the bullet had been handed
over
to the israelis to to investigate even
if the americans were present something
the palestinians had always said they
didn't want because they didn't believe
that it would be an unbiased and
transparent investigation we've just had
a statement from sharing about family a
long statement where it pretty much
backs that up saying that they're
incredulous
that it's been found inconclusive that
they expected more from the americans
particularly also that she's an american
citizen it also mentions uh accusing the
us of giving billions of dollars of
military aid to israel as it perpetuates
its occupation and killing of
palestinians and that it's going to
continue uh to call for an independent
investigation and justice uh for shalina
we've had responses now coming in from
multiple palestinian officials saying
pretty much the same thing that israel
should be held to account of course
there's no doubt uh on behalf of the
palestinian leadership or any
palestinian you speak to on the street
and indeed i think we need to remind our
viewers you know all of sharin's
colleagues on the ground on may 11th who
witnessed what happened say there's no
doubt that the israeli army
shot her and killed her and also
multiple international media
investigations that broke it down
forensically
analyzed by military experts when it
came to location of fire when it came to
the location on the ground when it came
to the ballistic sounds all of them
concluding
that israel was responsible for her
death we've had reaction from the
israeli defense minister benny ganz he's
saying that israel always strives to
find the truth and that unfortunately in
his words this time it wasn't possible
but laying the blame at palestinian
gunmen who were firing in the area at
the time of course this video has been
analyzed extensively at the time it
didn't sound like there was an exchange
of fire only fire coming from one
specific direction so when it comes to
the palestinians this is not a surprise
this is as expected um and i think as
you were talking about there with mike
hanna also interestingly this
the americans pretty much i think trying
to pour cold water on this ahead of
president joe biden's visit at the end
of next week the americans had been
pressurizing the palestinians to hand
over the bullet something the
palestinians didn't want to do because
they wanted to put this to bed
ahead of that visit
very very briefly steph i wonder what
this in your eyes means in terms of
trust
between palestinians in the united
states of course the bullet was handed
over on trust that there would be
a thorough inquiry and one that
would give us a fuller understanding of
what had happened what does this do
in terms of that relationship
well it is already a relationship that's
uh let's say very broken particularly
since the trump administration and the
palestinians at this point feel that
this administration even though in words
it's been more supportive and it's taken
certain steps but it really hasn't taken
the bigger steps to mend what the trump
administration ruined so there is very
little trust as well you're now
pointing out a very important point the
palestinians had you know consecutively
said we do not want israel part of this
investigation in the end this was the
israelis investigating the bullet
forensically with the presence of the
americans some things that they didn't
want one palestinian official already
recently saying it was a mistake to hand
over the bullet what did we expect and
so what the americans have managed to do
now is pretty much
almost take the responsibility of the
israelis for any accountability because
if the israelis had said
well it looks like yes one of our
soldiers shot sharing
was a mistake
there would be calls for a trial for
justice for accountability what these
what the americans seem to have done so
taken uh that pressure off israel and
said well it looks like they did it
but they didn't uh do it on purpose so
you know it's a tragic mistake and let's
just all move on well obviously
shadeen's family her colleagues her
friends and the palestinian leadership
uh are gonna make sure that doesn't
happen but i think you know it's very
difficult if you don't have the weapon
to to to trace it to the bullet um it's
going to be very difficult to be able to
categorically say who exactly fired that
shot but again when it comes to the
palestinians her family and everyone
present at the time they are under no
doubt as to who killed her
steph decker in west jerusalem thank you
now let's take a look at what's happened
since shireen was killed by israeli
forces at the time of the attack she was
in a camp for palestinian refugees who
were expelled from their land in 1948
hours after her death the israeli
government began circulating video on
social media suggesting she was likely
shot by a palestinian fighter it later
changed that account saying it's
possible its soldiers may have killed
her
palestinian president mahmoud abbas
rejected a proposal for a joint
investigation with israel instead he
pledged to take the case to the
international criminal court there have
been protests from ramallah to east
jerusalem and israeli forces attacked
her funeral with mourners saying even in
death shireen managed to show the world
the face of israel's occupation
since her killing media outlets
including the associated press cnn the
new york times and washington post have
announced their own investigations which
found
was likely killed by israeli fire the
palestinian authority investigation
found abu allah was deliberately killed
by israeli forces on the same day
al-jazeera said it would file a case
with the international criminal court in
june the palestinian foreign minister
took the results of the investigation to
the icc riyadh maliki urged prosecutors
to bring to justice those responsible
for shireen's killing
marwan bashar is in al jazeera senior
political analyst he joins us now from
skype from paris marwan of course
for those who are hoping for a fuller
sense of what happened that fateful day
um this will be a moment of frustration
and disappointment
yes absolutely
although it was important that under
pressure of american
media and various international
uh outfit that that the biden
administration was forced at least to
say
that it is likely uh the shooting
uh the killing
of uh sherina barkley
took place
from
the israeli military forces
uh in fact they are assassination units
that are
usually sent uh to the places like
jeanine we know that there's a pattern
of that sort of behavior on the part of
the israeli occupation
sending
special forces as they call them or
assassination units
and sharing was killed by one of those
but i think from the very beginning and
i've said it
countless times uh over the past few
weeks
that the israeli's intention was to get
us lost in the details
uh as soon as uh the the the news came
out the tragic news of the of sharing's
killing israel suddenly began to muddy
the water about that this could be
palestinian shooters and and so on and
so forth but slowly but surely the
evidence was established that this must
have come from the israeli side
that the israeli assassination units are
always on standby to do such a thing
they have done
countless such killings over the past
few months and years
we also know that there's a pattern
leave
a pattern that started with the killing
of green attacking her house that very
afternoon
and then attacking her funeral
the next day
so clearly israel
has been quite
flagrant if you will in its behavior
towards the journalist towards
palestinian towards a
palestinian-american
hoping uh that uh it will uh get away
with it uh and especially
uh with the impurity provided by the
united states
what uh i find quite remarkable here is
that we seem to have been marched all
the way to the edge and we are offered
the possibility of joining the dots
ourselves rather than us investigators
doing that for us why
do you feel at this particular moment in
time the u.s are not prepared to go the
extra mile
well clearly
we are only uh what ten days nine days
before uh president biden arrives in
israel and in palestine
and clearly the uh the u.s
administration would want to put this
behind it
without sounding uh too critical of
either side the palestinian or the
israeli or even though a crime was
committed
i personally as someone who has followed
u.s israeli relations for a good number
of years
i am
bewildered
by president biden's behavior towards
israel
he's a bit of an enigma to me
in the sense that israel continuously
humiliates him
and he continuously comes out with a
smug smiling defending israel
as the man the president who loves
israel who's a christian and yet a
zionist who will always have israel's
back no matter what so he in fact has
been israel's defense lawyer for as many
years as we know almost
40 years a senator
more years eight years of that as vice
president and now as president there's
something about biden
that he personally or politically
continues to support israel no matter
how much israel humiliates him and we
know from media reports
credible media reports that the by the
administration asked israel not
to attack the funeral the day after the
assassination of our colleague and yet
israelis did that deliberately to tell
biden to butt out of its own what it
calls business which is the business of
the occupation the business of the
humiliation of the palestinians of
course
what underpins all of this of course is
the shooting wouldn't have happened at
all if there wasn't an occupation
absolutely and not just any kind of
occupation it's an occupation that's
been going on for over 50 years
but it's also
an operation that took place against a
refugee camp by the name of janine and
you mentioned that neve in the beginning
of your report just now but what do we
mean by that because for our viewers
around the world it's really good to
refresh the memories
this is not just
a refugee camp
because the defense minister of israel
just said that there are terrorists
operating from
civilian areas what civilian areas what
terrorists but this is a refugee camp
that's almost 70 years old since 1953
it's a 70 year old camp
half of its population are elderly or
children it's a concentration camp over
one square kilometers where over 13 000
people live
and not only in a dense lakes cram
circumstance most of them hungry most of
them unemployed but also next door or
within
the you know the realm of a city of
janine that's
half of its own population are refugees
and these are part of
58 other palestinian refugee camps
hosting some 1.3 million palestinians
for over 70 years so you can imagine the
frustration the anger the pent-up
violence
in those areas
where israel the united states even the
palestinian authority i must say would
not address their grievances calling
them a terrorists calling them civilian
areas
calling them a
okay target for the israeli occupation
that's just not just flagrant not just
unethical or
immoral it is criminal
and what our colleague sharin aboutly
was doing that day
what she did for 20-plus years
was give voice to those voiceless
palestinians
whether it's against israeli occupation
or against their own authority but these
voices palestinians did not have any
voice
and international media outlets are not
covering it it is to the credit of al
jazeera english that continues to
transmit credible reports from the
refugee camps from the streets of the
occupied west bank to the rest of the
world and it is thanks to al jazeera and
its journalists it's credible
journalists it is forum
that israel and the united states were
for the first time obliged forced pushed
nudged and really pressured into looking
into this question because israel kills
palestinian innocent palestinians all
the time but this time thanks to al
jazeera's forum and because it's
microphone i must be you know i must say
that with pride it is louder than the
israeli public relations spin that has
tried to get away with this but al
jazeera journalists are not just any
victims in this case it had to be an
american palestinian and an incredible
palestinian jurors who were doing her
job as she did it for over 20 years they
killed her
apparently in a targeted killing by an
assassination unit and yet israel would
muddy the water and the united states
would help them doing that while it
happened in a crime scene called a
refugee camp under occupation
marwan bashara al jazeera senior
political analyst thank you
okay well let's speak to lina abu akala
now a niece of shari naba aberwegler
she's joining me live from geneva thank
you so much for your time firstly
your response to these findings
uh thank you so much for having me uh
first and foremost uh
from day one israel has been trying to
change the narrative and using the
bullet has been their uh one of their
many narratives but at the end of the
day this is not the end
the results that concluded that the
bullet is
cannot be determined if it was from the
israeli side
to us
that's just
the investigation the entire
investigation is disappointing
considering the fact that we are not
aware of any of the
of the re of the process we were not
there was no transparency uh we were not
given enough information regarding the
investigation and we had found out about
it last minute
so to us we still continue to call for a
transparent and a just investigation
and we call on the un especially the icc
to handle the case of shilin with the
same enthusiasm it has been showing to
ukraine as rightfully so
so regarding the results um
it is intentional yes shirin was killed
intentionally
while
the u.s claimed that
that the bullet was likely from israeli
soldiers does provide us with some kind
of a cold comfort but that's not enough
we still call for accountability we
still call for justice and for the u.s
to actually carry out an independent
investigation free from any political
pressure
and uh to provide its citizen shilling
the right
investigation that she deserves as a
citizen of course initially there were
claims from the israeli side that the
bullets were fired by palestinian gunmen
possibly what this ballistics report
does not stay in any way that that was
the case does that provide you any
degree
of comfort any degree of of hope that
the focus can continue to be
put
on uh the the idf who were there clearly
in abundance in janine on that day
yes of course and as i mentioned earlier
this is some sort of a comfort but it's
not enough however all other previous
reports have clearly indicated that it
was
uh
it was the israeli soldiers who shot and
killed chilean so
that to us is important and we will
continue to be seeking justice and uh
using that as a sort as part of the
evidence
in terms of the reaction there um
amongst supporters of shireen and
members of the family as well
this must come as a moment of deep
frustration as well it does feel very
much like an uphill struggle for you and
the rest of the family
of course it's uh it's very
disappointing but at the same time
at the same time it's not discouraging
we will continue to fight for justice we
will continue to fight for
accountability and end to this impunity
because this result that we received
today it just adds on to the impunity
that israel enjoys but we will not
uh be discouraged and we will continue
on our path to
for justice and accountability
and what are your what are your thoughts
on on the international reaction as well
do you think more can be done around the
world to to focus the the uh pressure on
on on israel
of course there are definitely there's
so much more that can be done from the
from uh from states as they have their
obligation third states have an
obligation to protect human rights
violations everywhere and this is their
obligation to talk about what happened
to shireen and to hold israel
accountable and second all journalists
should also take up uh their platforms
and to continue to advocate because
shilin attended was a journalist and she
was targeted and that she's not the
first journalist and not the last to be
killed by israeli forces therefore there
needs to be an entire
movement not just by journalists but
also as i mentioned state civil society
the un and the icc we saw from the
beginning of the occupation of
russia on ukraine how the icc was
carrying out an investigation the same
should be done to
uh to shilin's case and to palestine
shireen is not an exception palestine is
not an exception and we need to continue
states need to continue to call out uh
to call out for justice and
accountability we need to put an end to
this double standards and the hypocrisy
that's been seen in the international
community lina abubakar niece of our
colleague shiri nabarak club thank you
very much for your time
thank you for having me
now let's bring in samsung zaheer human
rights lawyer and a litigator for
palestinians at israel's supreme court
she joins us from haifa
um can i start by summarizing what we
know so far
we know that it looks like the israeli
army killed shireen it looks like in
their eyes it was a mistake but the
results say the uh so the team behind
this investigation are the results are
inconclusive
because the bullet was badly damaged
from a legal perspective
what do these findings mean to you
uh good evening first of all we're
talking about a political examination
of the bullet and hence as well the way
that the conclusion of the examination
was narrated we are not talking about a
criminal investigation this is one thing
the second thing is that in order to do
a criminal investigation and get out
with the conclusions which wasn't done
by the americans while examining the
bullet there was no word about the match
with the weapons knowing that every
sniper unit at the israeli military uh
forces must have documentation not only
of the bullets and not only of their
activities but also of their weapons
there was no word about uh
examining what the witnesses said any
other evidences there was nothing about
contradiction of this conclusion with
other investigations including the un
human rights commissioner which was
released only ten days ago which is an
independent which was an independent
monitoring examination not a criminal
one i must say but still after examining
all the evidence and witnesses indicated
and concluded that there was intention
by the israeli military forces that
sharing was killed by them intentionally
after checking videos witnesses evidence
and and so on and having said all that i
must say that the only uh
institution or body that is eligible to
make such a conclusion is the icc and
therefore the palestinian response to
the fact that they must continue that
they want to continue before the icc the
international national criminal court is
the right move because this is the only
institution that really can provide the
conclusions now on the other hand i also
must say that i was not surprised by the
conclusion everyone knows including the
israelis that sharing was shot already
from day one by an israeli army by a
bullet from the israeli army even the
americans knew that the fact that there
was all the time the contradictions uh
in in the in the american narrative or
in the american story from day one the
fact that they never even denied it the
fact that they're trying to blame the
palestinians even the u.n commissioner
report and the cnn and the washington
post and the ap all of them said that
there was no presence of any palestinian
civilians or resistance at a at the area
so this is not surprising because the
conclusion of the american examination
of the bullet is basically political
because yes by then
and if and if indeed this was a criminal
investigation and not heavy politicized
as you say
what would be made of this ballistic
evidence would it be challenged in a
court of law
first of all um
there have been thousands of
palestinians that have been killed by
israeli snipers and israeli soldiers
take along uh more than 60 or 62
palestinians that were killed on the
west bank only from the beginning of
2022. let us not forget all of all all
the ones in gaza that were as well
killed and assassinated and not and
neither of one of these cases
did israel say that they cannot conduct
an investigation because they don't have
the bullet the bullet is a very
important thing in criminal procedures
but it is only one evidence in all the
criminal evidence that there are and
what israel is trying to make is
basically as lena
is getting into the small details in
order to uh
to to mislead in order to basically get
out and give account or impunity to
itself out of the greater picture uh
gans also if we look at the israeli
minister of defense uh response on the
fact that there were palestinians
in the area and that it is inconclusive
also says a lot which basically is the
political motive to provide impunity to
any act of war crime conducted by the
israeli military whether against chilean
abraham or against the thousands of
palestinians and the u.s which is also
not surprising the u.s has been backing
up the lack of accountability to the
israelis not just from trump era but
also from before if i can remind you
since even castle the goldstone report
the u.n inquiries on the wars on gaza in
2008 2012 2004
and even
a public prosecutor's uh a decision to
open uh investigation a a on israeli war
crime
usa never really supported that and they
all the time support
providing israel accountability a lack
of accountability and full impunity for
political reasons only
human rights lawyer and litigator for
palestinians at israel's supreme court
thank you very much for that
thank you for having